if I want to keep it a buck literally I
haven't stopped eating this pizza and I
beg Nicole for this chili oil oh my God
you really are part of the first week
Beast
[Music]
family Brooklyn is hollowed ground when
it comes to Pizza the dish may have been
born in Naples Italy but to many it was
perfected right here in neighborhoods
like Midwood Graves end Park Slope and
Coney Island today the burrow is still
home to some of the best pizzeria on the
planet ranging from family-owned
institutions to New School slice shops
balancing Innovation with tradition to
better understand what makes Brooklyn
peace is so special I'm first meeting up
with my good friend Frank penelo Frank
was born and raised in Benson Hurst
Brooklyn and is the chef owner behind
williamsburg's best pizza today Frank is
taking me to one of his favorite old
school slice shops Luigi's and Park
Slope where second generation owner
Giovani lenzo is keeping his family's
Legacy alive after 50 years of
[Music]
business what do you guys think made
this place last so long and still a
staple in Brooklyn I don't know if it's
just like the facade outside it reminds
me of my childhood and the pizzeria I
grew up going to but then when you walk
in here and you see Gio making the pies
and you could just kind of feel that
family feeling like it's a true Family
Restaurant yeah I think um there's
really not many places I feel like in
New York things uh things come and they
go so quickly but the really special
places last a test of time and this is
certainly one of them Gio when I think
of a classic New York Pizzeria I think
of this place can you tell me how your
parents came to open this Pizzeria in
the 1970s they had a dream when they
came here they both worked my father
worked in a cemetery 8: to 5 from 5:00
to 4:00 in the morning he worked in a
pizzeria my mother worked in a sweat
shop they put everything together cuz
they never spent anything they made
everything at home cuz everything is bad
outside don't eat it it's no good for
you old school old school yeah and they
saved and my father bought the building
and it took him 6 months he open up the
pizzeria so at what point did you say to
yourself I want to you know pick up what
my parents did and just continue the
Dream well I'm the typical kid that
grows up in a family where the father
has a business that thinks he's smarter
than the father I went to college my
father went to the second grade here I
am I thought I was swed my father really
wasn't after I got out of colge I went
to work for a company I lasted not even
a year because I came right back here
wow I couldn't handle being behind the
desk and I wanted to make pizza I
realized that I love making pizza my
father called me a donkey my whole life
St all this money I spend on school and
he wants to make
pizza
sham I'm going to show you how to make a
Brooklyn South Brooklyn Pizza I have to
tell you it's just an honor to be back
here press on the outside not the middle
the outside oh so even the crust even
the crust the crust will show up no
matter what what happens is when you
start stretching it to 18 19 in this
part has to be you see people have weak
midd and people say that pizza flops
yeah well leave the middle till leave
the middle it stretches as you make it
bigger so for years I was always scared
to touch my crust the Italians told you
that one right don't touch the crust me
everything God forbid you're aopo and
you touch the the crust holy [__] am I
doing it right yeah that's it and as you
do it you're actually turning it flip it
over flip it over that's it just go like
this
pick that but listen if the do screams
we both run
but funny right ready go
yeah and then put it on the board okay I
got it open so I'm just happy that I got
it open how far out do you usually go to
the crust all the way my father used to
hate it where's the cheese on the crust
my father used to make sure to crust
that cheese how much cheese cheese do
you put are you a Cheesy guy no okay not
too much cheese sace and bread just
sauce and bread okay I could live on
that if you put me in jail just give me
sauce and bread and I'll be happier than
anywhere
else my name is Lisa Lanzo and I'm Aisa
Lanzo we are giovan's sisters and we are
the owners of Luigi's Pizza we have a
lot of Pride being here my parents
worked their butts off so my mother
worked here she worked at home she was
definitely
like the steel behind my father she was
a soul she was a heart that kept
everything going are you proud of your
brother oh extremely honestly the hours
that he puts in he gets so busy and so
bombarded with orders and he takes 2
minutes for himself just two minutes to
sit down give himself a breather and
then he's back out there making sure
everybody is fed making sure everybody's
happy and we're just proud of him that's
why his customers love him Luigi's Pizza
is the best pizza Pizza in Brooklyn in
New York you know what I've had Italian
pizza sorry Brooklyn is where it's at
and Luigi is is number one as far as
we're
concerned God o thin and
crispy I've been dying to try this pizza
I cannot wait salute sal sal oh my
God so delicious to me it's very much
the prototypical New York slice except
on on like the highest level it's got
like a nice weight to it you know so it
doesn't feel flimsy or too thin when you
take a bite of it you taste everything
you taste the acidity from the sauce the
creaminess from the cheese and then that
delicious crust underneath really
delicious so good I love what I do right
so every bit of love goes into it so
yeah I well I can taste the love so
good Brooklyn is still old school but
there's also a new God of Brooklyn bread
pizza chefs who are continuing to serve
up some of the best slices in the
country and in sheep's head Bay Chef s
Carino is Bridging the old world with
the new with its critically acclaimed
slice shop Luchia like Gio s has
Brooklyn Pizza in his blood his parents
restaurant Papa Leon operated in sheeps
head Bay for more than four decades he
opened Luchia to shake up the South
Brooklyn slice scene and add his own
twist to his family's recipes you know I
love a neighborhood shop especially one
like this that's so nostalgic but most
importantly I love that you open it up
right here in the neighborhood in Sheeps
at Bay thank you so much why she head B
the story starts here uh it starts in
1974 at papon was my mom and dad's spot
I grew up there grew up working for them
my whole life my biggest fear was that
sheep head Bay was undercovered right
that we're a part of South Brooklyn that
doesn't really get the attention from
any sort of food media period with the
exception of like three places and a lot
of them are part of this Old Guard that
just always existed some of them 50 60
years old some of them 100 years old and
at first I was going to run away from it
because I was terrified I was scared
what were you scared of were you scared
that people wouldn't come like exactly
they want to troop all the way to she I
feel like what you did was a great idea
because the trends are changing you know
what I mean like I feel like more people
are willing to troop anywhere as long as
the pizza is fantastic and you know you
don't have that problem right if you
told me that you've been living in the
burrow for 5 or 10 years but you've
never gone to Coney Island or you've
never seen Brighton Beach you've not
experienced these beautiful parts of the
burrow that exist outside of what is
considered popular Brooklyn now you're
just cheating yourself out of a really
fun day do you think your parents are
like super proud of you for what you've
done it's a lot of pressure right I
think yeah I think for the first time
probably in a in a handful of years they
are yeah I got an old school Sicilian
dad we'll talk for like 30 seconds and
he cries at the drop of a hat now and
stuff you know it's special it means a
lot to
me all right Nicole we're going to make
a vodka pie we use a local fresh
mozzarella from uh Leoni oh I love Leone
my faor actually Le is so classic
Brooklyn My Le Leoni lini yes I like a
cold vodka sauce it's the same as like
having you know having a family member's
red sauce the following day it's always
better one of the things that people
loved that Mom and Dad did was the vodka
sauce one of the main jobs of coming
back to sheep head was getting the Vodka
SAU as close to what they used to make
as possible so now we're going to make
the uh caramel Picante which means in
Italian it means basically spicy candy
okay yeah we're going to go with a
regular pie base so now we're going to
go in with the cherry peppers right now
we got the good cup and Char we got good
cup and Char pepperonis I like to put
them on top for obvious reasons the
closer they are to the heat the more
likely they are to be a beautiful cup
and Char so now we're going to do the
clam pie so our clams are beautiful
fresh chopped Cherry Stones they're simp
SED and reduced into a white wine butter
reduction oo and those are thinly sliced
pieces of garlic yeah as Frank would say
oh
my stop vka pie is ready woo at that
I'll join you it's so crispy and
beautiful look at that a I'll meet it
I'll meet it right where it's at
ah so delicate it's so delicate oh my
gosh it's so good
all right M delicious this is the
caramel Picante M it's going to be
pretty hard to top the Vodka slice yeah
this is different though this is fun so
good to the good life cheers thank you
so
much you know I just love a good
pepperoni and the cherry peppers are
nice not too much heat the basil she had
been so lucky to have you look at that
clamp pie ooh some nice lemon and all of
it on there
right M that clam is delicious oh my
gosh oh my God this my favorite right
here thank you so much delicious thank
you if South Brooklyn is all about
history and tradition then North
Brooklyn has become synonymous with
what's next few neighborhoods in New
York City have more top tier pizzerias
per capita than Williamsburg but still
one slice shop stands out from the rest
lustry has quickly become one of the
most talked about peteras in the five
burrows blending Brooklyn slice culture
with Italian technique so today I'm
sharing a pie with Native brooklynite
and food TV icon Adam Richmond to see if
lindry really lives up to the
hype I'm Nick bag Lille and I'm one of
the co-owners of lindry Pizzeria Street
gangster
365 hi I'm mimila I'm one of the coowner
of lindri Pia I think he a is a
combination between like Italian style
and New York style M's Italian artisinal
ways about thinking about the dough and
the quality behind the dough and like my
New York style of thinking about slices
being simple and classic our dough is
like 48 hour fermentation we don't mess
behind the sauce we use Bianca denapoli
mix s they're both California based
organic tomatoes with alone moisture
Grande mozzarella cheese that's classic
New York style so we're baking our pie
uh 33 CI which is I think it's 630 I
would say is a little bit more High than
the usual New York style pizza the goal
when the pizza comes out is to be
crunchy but also have a good chew to it
it has to be in between I like when the
pizza when you fold it and it makes that
crack on the bottom the bath is the most
popular definitely we sell like crazy
amount of Batha every week here I feel
like the combination of like hot pizza
and cold bat on top when it come out
like it's a nice balance it's a real
merge of styles because you take the bur
off you have a regular slice put the
Bata on it's Italian as much as you can
come in and get a barata slice you can
get soft serve you can get a Mia you can
get a donut you can get an olive oil
cake I think what makes the pizza great
here is the fact that we're always here
our team is strong blar his face out
like Jerry Springer you know because
they're going to start poaching him this
is masimo Jr you know this is the secret
behind Pizza all these are the secret
yeah like this is the backbone if there
was a backbone Emoji it' be these three
guys oh my God now now Manny's going to
get upset in the man come
here
sorry sorry
means this is heard so much about so
delicious
enoy this this is what we're known for
here at lustry the regular pie but our
twist we put BR on top so you get a
really hot pizza with cool Bara on top
you can always eat it when it's fresh
enjoy the pizza all right thank you so
much Che I got to put a little chil oh
I'm going to go naked I want to see this
one this is a game called eat enough
Pizza to get to the Bara oh yes Cheers
Cheers M if you look at it from the side
and this is something that Chris Bianco
taught me you can actually see that
fermentation to me pizza is not just
about the toppings you're eating the
plate you're eating the serving vessel
it's awesome I can I tell you my
favorite thing about this a the cold
Bara on the hot pizza amazing the fresh
basil hits the Heat and then starts be
becoming perfumey I think this is a a
Triumph of contrast the creamy with the
crunchy the Smoky with the sweet it's
it's great well you know the thing that
I love about it that makes it so
Brooklyn to me is the slight Flex
there's a flex with lustry there's a
flex in the slice you know what I mean
because they're saying it's fast you're
going to get a pizza fast but it's still
sexy it's still light and crispy it's
still high ingredients it's still
authentic clearly you have like two real
culinarians you know in Residence here
in a great staff M and they're making
that kind of bougie fork and knife pizza
for the folks like me that just miss a
good slice
joint as a native brooklynite how have
you seen the piece scene change over the
years it's a great question to be honest
Williamsburg is not the Brooklyn I grew
up and I tell people like there was like
the Brooklyn with like ebbit field and
trolley dodging then there's the one of
the ironic mustaches trucker hats and
interpole yes I grew up in that middle
period where didn't nor I want anything
to [__]
and usually it was a place called gos a
place called Tony a place called m a
painting of the Coliseum done by they're
like their cousin you know my cousin
Gino he go with the paints you know the
thing is it was the Nostalgia and now I
think in Williamsburg when you have a
stylish populace fine dining Michelin
star restaurants you're finding some of
the old school slice shops trying to up
their game to catch up to places like
Linda tree because more places are
bringing elev ated Pizza to the masses
and the places that were the old school
slice shops they have had to adapt and
change or they are getting wiped
[Music]
out Brooklyn does not have a monopoly on
New York Pizza Staten Island Manhattan
the Bronx and queens are all home to
some incredible slices but to me
Brooklyn Remains the epicenter so do you
guys feel like Brooklyn is still the
pizza capital of the world like what
makes Brooklyn so special you know for a
while
you saw a big change in Manhattan when
it came to Pizza it was all the dollar
slices right but in Brooklyn especially
when you come to neighborhoods like this
there's a lot of history and a lot of
Pizzeria that have been around for a
long time that are carry on Legacy where
the bottom line isn't the most important
thing maybe in Manhattan it is but in
Brooklyn it's more about Community it's
more about family and it's more about I
think the commitment to being great I
had a guy asked me the other day says
you know you're well off right you got
to be all these years here why would you
come to work every day cuz I I'm not
working I love being here this is my
socialization what's the best part of
your life was when you sit at the dinner
table with your family this is my family
[Music]
yes
w